Thank you, Mr. President.
In 20, 20, 22,
you presided over
a bipartisan international coalition
to support Ukraine.
How will you keep that coalition
from fraying in
2023 and President Zelensky,
welcome to Washington
on this beautiful winter day.
What is your message
to the American people?
When answering your question first?
I'm not at all worried about holding
the alliance together.
Naito and the European Union,
as well as other nations
use the interim agreement.
I assume this is simultaneous.
All right.
Okay.
I've never seen Naito or the EU
more united about anything at all,
and I see no sign of there
being any change
We all know what's at stake here.
Our European partners,
all the more so they fully understand it.
This is about we've never seen
a major invasion of a European country
since World War Two,
and they see no signs
that Putin is going to do anything
to change that
unless we resist
and we help the Ukrainians resist.
We all know what's at stake.
The very idea of sovereignty, the U.N.
charter, Putin
thought he would weaken Naito.
Instead, he strengthened Naito.
I once said to him
that if we talk about the
he want wanted to see the,
you know, Europe end up being
dividing the.
And instead, what did he do?
He produced
a more united Europe with Sweden.
And Finland join it.
So I don't see
any reason to believe
there will be any lessening of support.
And as we reach out to our NATO
allies, our secretary of defense
and the secretary of state,
we get continued support
not only there, but also
from around the world, from Japan
and many other countries as well.
So I feel very good about the solidarity
of support for Ukraine.
Thank you for your question.
Thank you very much.
You asked me on your cruise, but done.
You know,
I think I will tell you
very simple things
which are very important for me
and I and I think so that we have
the same values
and the same understanding of the life,
the sense of the life.
My message, I wish you peace.
I think that is the main thing.
And you understand it only when the war
in your country,
when somebody like these terrorists
from Russia
come to your hardships
And I wish you to see your children, life
and adults.
And I wish you to see your children.
And they will go during and watch this
and to see their children.
I think that is the main thing.
What I can wish you
and of course, to be together with us
generally
because we really fight
for our common victory
against this tyranny.
That is real life
and we will win.
And I really want
win together.
Thanks so much.
Not want.
Sorry.
I'm sure
that
you call on one of your people.
Press person.
Yeah.
The blast came
Yes, we counter.
Yeah. Thank you.
Dmitry.
An option to Ukraine and television.
President Zelensky, President Biden.
I got a question to both of you.
But firstly, as Ukraine and I mean it,
I want to thank you, United States,
for supporting my country and,
you know, my families in Ukraine.
And I definitely understand
they will not be alive today
if America will not support my country,
both politically and militarily.
So thank you for this.
It's unreal.
And because of my question,
we enter a new phase of this war
and you definitely discussed today
which path to choose
how the war could come to an end
and what's next
will turn into a new counter-offensive
or some kind of peace talks.
So, Mr. Biden, Mr.
Zelensky, could you share your vision?
What's the fair way to end this war?
And how do you understand this war?
So Final Peace Thank you.
My my view.
Your guy.
I think we have. For me.
I see. I see.
Although I like it very much.
All right, I'll get
where we are.
Porcelli, as
you have started this question,
I'm sorry.
Sometimes I switch on my media filling up
with Charleston, which was started
by stating that your family is in Kiev
and without
the assistance of the United States.
This is absolutely true.
The US leadership in this assistance is
great,
but it's not strong.
And again, I would like to remind you
that know family will be in danger.
And without the armed forces of Ukraine
should appreciate the very important
that concerns your questions.
First, say.
What would you like to hear
Just please.
I don't know.
I don't know what just this is.
It's a very philosophical description.
If there is
just war, I don't know.
You know, for all of us, for peace
and then just peace is different for me.
Is the president just peace
is no compromise?
Is it that still the sovereignty freedom
and territorial integrity of my country?
Scott Harris,
the payback for all the damages
inflicted by Russian aggression.
I'm sorry.
The reminder.
I'm talking about children a lot today.
But as a father,
I would like to emphasize,
you know, how many how many parents
lost their sons and daughters
on the front lines?
So what is justice for them, Glenny?
Money is nothing.
Money and no compensations
or reparations are off
when these are of no consequence.
They live by revenge.
O.J.,
I think this is a dead seven
tremendous tragedy.
And the longer the war for the
lasts,
the longer this aggression
lasts, there will be more
parents who live
for the sake of vengeance or revenge.
And I know a lot of people like that
with civil war.
So they can't be any just peace
in the war that was imposed on us
by these.
I don't know how to describe that
because we are in the White House
and I can't find the proper language.
So these Inhumans I would say
let me respond.
I think we have the
we share the exact same vision
and that free independent,
prosperous and secure
Ukraine is the vision.
We both want this war to end.
We both want it to end.
And as I've said,
it could end today
if Putin had any dignity
at all, did the right thing.
He just said, pull out.
But that's not going to happen.
Not going to happen.
It's not going to happen now.
So what comes next, we talked about today
was we're going to continue
to help Ukraine
succeed on the battlefield.
It can succeed in the battlefield.
Of our help
and the help of our European
allies and others
so that if
and when
President Zelensky is ready to talk
with the Russians,
he will be able to succeed as well,
because he will have
won on the battlefield. And,
you know, I
don't think we should underestimate
the impact this war is having on Russia
and the losses they're suffering.
And and you saw just
I think it was two days ago Putin
saying that
this is much tougher than he thought.
He thought he could break naito.
He thought he could break the West.
He thought he could break the alliance.
He thought he could be welcomed
by the Ukrainian people
that were Russian speakers.
He was wrong, wrong and wrong.
He continues to be wrong.
The sooner
he makes it's
clear that he cannot
possibly win this war.
That's when the time
we have to put this president
in a position to be able to decide
how he wants the war to end
My turn on
this.
Yeah.
Phil Mattingly, mathematically of CNN
Thank you, Mr.
President. Welcome, Mr. President.
It's president to start with you.
Your advisers often talk
about how important,
how critically important
you do face to face interaction.
I'm wondering,
after spending
two plus hours face to face
with President Zelinsky,
what you learned or what
you took
from the meeting that
perhaps you couldn't glean
or learn in the phone
calls or video conferences
and somewhat tied to that?
Was there any discussion
related to the U.S.
assessment
that Russia
would not take escalatory action
now that patriots are being sent, will be
a Patriot battery will be delivered?
Let me answer the first question.
The first part of your question is
you know,
I get kidded for saying that there is
all politics is personal.
It's all about
looking someone in the eye.
And I mean it sincerely.
I don't think there's any
any any substitute
for sitting down face to face
with a friend or foe
and looking them in the eye.
And that's exactly
what's happened in this moment.
We've done that more than once.
We're going to continue to do it
in the winter setting in.
And Putin is
increasingly going
after civilian targets
as women and children
and orphanages, this guy as well.
But but he's going to fail
and he's going to fail
he's already failed
because he now knows that there's
no way
he's ever going to occupy all of Ukraine.
There's no way
in which he's
going to be accepted
by the Ukrainian people.
And so he's failed in the past and was
very important
for him and everyone else to see.
The president, Lynskey and I are united
to countries together
to make sure he can not succeed.
And I think I may be mistaken,
but I know I judge every leader
by the way,
they what they say
to me, their consistency
and looking beyond this guy has in his
to his very soul is who he says he is.
It's clear who he is.
He's willing to
give his life for his country
and all the folks who
came with him today.
And so I think it's
he important
and important
for him to know
we are going
to do everything in our power,
everything in our power
to see that he succeeds.
What was the second part
of your question?
I just asked if you would discuss
how the U.S.
calculated the escalatory effect
of sending a Patriot
missile battery to Ukraine?
I did not discuss that at all
with with the president, but I we do not.
It's a defensive system.
It's a defensive weapon system.
It's not escalatory is defensive
and it's easy to not.
And we'd love to not have to have them
use it to stop the attacks.
President Zelensky, again, welcome.
Well,
you mentioned earlier
that you wanted to make this trip
for a while now.
Why now?
And also,
can you tell me what you think
the message you are sending to President
Putin is given the fact that 24 hours ago
you were on the ground in the front lines
with artillery echoing behind you,
and now you find yourself
in the White House
standing next to the president
on this joke.
Thank you very much for your question.
Sure.
As to
your key message,
what is the message for Putin?
Yesterday,
I am standing here in the United States
with President Biden on the same podium
because I respect him
as a person,
as a president, as a human being for his
position.
And for me, this is a historic moment.
I can send messages
to President Biden, for example,
If it's not serious, you said
what's going to happen
after patriots are installed?
After that, we will send another signal
to President Biden
that we would like to get more patriots
and we're worried that is our ally.
We are in the war. I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry.
That is my appreciation.
To President Putin
in 2019
we had Normandy meeting in 2019
I became the president of Ukraine.
And at that time we were sending
maximum messages to President Putin
telling him
that there should not be
a full scale invasion
to stop aggression,
to renew our territory and
territorial integrity,
to find diplomatic solution.
Well, God forbid
we should not have a full scale war.
At that time, we said it won't happen.
He was lying.
So what kind of message
I can send him after he actually.
If
Ukraine is destroyed,
our life is destroying our life.
He can even go further
somewhere where
the Soviet Union stayed before this.
So he might want to invade
those territories, too.
I believe that there is something
more to
learn
about his
inadequate approach to the world.
Why we need to send him a message.
He needs to be interested in
getting attention from the world
because he is not the subject
of civilized people.
He should be interested in trying to save
something of his culture
and history of his country.
So that's his problem.
Now,
in presenting this,
this will be the last question
Only one plus one TV
channel
wins a full scale invasion are started.
U.S.
officials are sad that Ukraine
cannot receive Petros
because, as you
said, it might be unnecessary escalation.
And now it is happening right now.
Today it is happening.
And now Ukraine desperately
needs more capabilities,
including long range missiles,
attack arms,
maybe I sound naive, but
can we make a long story short
and give Ukraine all
capabilities it needs and
liberate
all territories
arouses sooner than later?
Thank you.
His answer is yes.
I agree
Let me be straightforward with you.
Look,
the fact is that
it is important to remember
that before Russia invaded.
We dedicated an enormous amount
of security assistance to Ukraine.
And and we've given Ukraine
what they needed
when they needed to defend themselves.
And since the invasion, that has resulted
in more
than $20 billion
in terms of security assistance.
Just today, I approved
another $1.8 billion
in additional assistance
Ukraine
for it to succeed on the battlefield.
And we're focused on working
with allies and partners
to generate capability in four key areas
air defense.
As now as we know today,
the Patriot is the best of that.
Secondly, is to and we're looking to
do more.
We provided
hundreds of advanced
artillery systems and dozens
from dozens of countries Thirdly,
we work with partners
to get Ukraine tanks
and other armored vehicles.
And fourthly,
we've announced today
another 200,000 rounds
of additional ammunition.
Do you say,
why don't we just give Ukraine everything
there is to give?
Well, for two reasons.
One, there's an entire alliance
that is critical to stay with Ukraine.
And the idea that we would give
Ukraine material
that is
fundamentally different
than is already going
there would have a prospect
of breaking up
Naito and breaking up the European Union
and the rest of the world.
We're going to give Ukraine what it needs
to be able
to defend itself, to be able
to succeed and succeed
in the battlefield.
And the other piece of this is,
you may recall one of the reasons why
I have spent
well won't tell you the calculation,
but I've spent
several hundred hours face to face
with our European allies
and the heads of state of those countries
and making the case as to why
it was overwhelmingly in their interest
that they continue to support Ukraine.
They understand it fully,
but they're not looking to go to war
with Russia.
They're not looking
for a third world war.
And I think it can all be avoided
by making sure that Ukraine
is able to succeed in the battlefield.
So anyway, there's more to say,
but I've probably already said too much.
Thank you.